[Música]
y economía en directo américa de france
24 ya me acompaña en el estudio jorge
hurtado jorge bienvenido muy buena
mañana del lunes vamos a iniciar
entonces nuestro segmento de economía
con el impago de rusia a su deuda
soberana que reporta a bloomberg reyes
que se este sería el primer impago de su
deuda soberana a extranjeros en más de
un siglo al final de este domingo
terminó ese periodo de gracia de 30 días
para pagar alrededor de 100 millones de
dólares en intereses que vencían el 27
de mayo rusia afirma que tiene el dinero
para pagarlo pero que debido a las
sanciones de occidente se ve obligada a
no hacerlo la semana pasada incluso
dijeron que pagarían 40 mil millones de
deuda soberana en rublos por una
situación de fuerza mayor
el kremlin afirma que no hay ninguna
razón para evocar un cese de pago de
rusia en respuesta a la publicación de
bloomberg vladimir putin firmó un
decreto en el que ordena que las
obligaciones frente a los eurobonos de
la federación rusa se reconocen como
cumplidas y se realizan en rublos rusia
acusa a occidente de impedir el pago de
su deuda con medidas como el bloqueo de
su depositario nacional por la unión
europea
renovación por eeuu de la licencia que
le permitía a moscú pagar temporalmente
su deuda en dólares jóvenes cambiamos de
información porque los líderes del g-7
estudian nuevas sanciones contra rusia
por su invasión a ucrania se habla de un
tope de precios para el petróleo ruso a
aumentar los aranceles sobre los
productos rusos e imponer nuevas
sanciones a cientos de funcionarios y
entidades que apoyan de cierta forma la
guerra la cumbre durará tres días en los
alpes alemanes y se esperan importantes
e importantes anuncios sobre rusia eeuu
dijo que el g7 prohibir a la importación
de oro ruso y el domingo el reino unido
anunció también la prohibición de
importación del nuevo oro ruso por un
valor de 16 mil seiscientos millones de
dólares esta medida de reino unido sería
en conjunto con canadá japón y eeuu pero
un alto funcionario de la administración
estadounidense adelantó que el anuncio
vendría de parte de todo el grupo del g7
durante la sesión este lunes los líderes
del g-7 se centraron en la agenda en
ucrania se espera también para hoy la
participación de cinco economías
democráticas emergentes como india
indonesia sudáfrica senegal
argentina para debatir temas como el
cambio climático y la energía
juárez que ya está noticia tuvo su
repercusión en los precios del oro así
es el oro al contado subió un 0 7% hasta
los mil 838 dólares la onza mientras los
futuros del oro en estados unidos o bien
un 0,5 por ciento a 1839 también rusia
es el tercer productor mundial de oro y
representa alrededor del 10 por ciento
de la producción mundial aunque el
aumento es leve en el precio del oro
refleja que la prohibición en el mercado
del oro son probablemente o serían muy
limitadas hay que tomar en cuenta que el
aumento de los tipos de interés que
están haciendo varios bancos centrales
del mundo tendrá un efecto negativo en
los precios del oro durante los próximos
seis meses según dicen algunos analistas
y en japon hay temores por escasez de
suministro de energía el gobierno
japonés advirtió que el suministro se
verá afectado en toques específicamente
y 8 prefecturas cercanas del este de
japón el exceso de capacidad de
generación bajará allí hasta un 3,7 por
ciento durante este lunes el ministerio
de economía comercio
según dijo el ministerio de economía
comercio e industria el gobierno pidió a
los ciudadanos que ahorren energía
frente a una posible escasez en medio
del calor del verano que golpea la
capital el suministro de energía en
japón es escaso por el cierre de muchas
de sus centrales nucleares desde el
tsunami y la catástrofe nuclear de
fukushima en 2011 el país también se
enfrenta a una posible escasez de
combustibles fósiles incluido el gas
natural debido al conflicto en ucrania y
las sanciones contra rusia 'jorge cómo
están los indicadores económicos hoy
lunes bueno empezamos en europa las
acciones subieron a su nivel más alto en
dos semanas apoyadas por las mineras y
las acciones petroleras ya que la
relajación de las restricciones del cobi
19 en china impulsó los precios de las
materias primas en asia por supuesto
esto repercute ahí hay un repunte de los
mercados asiáticos después de que china
suavizará aún más las restricciones del
cobi e inclusive ayudará a impulsar el
índice de referencia msc y para las
acciones mundiales
la cifra es 9 mil 400 millones de
dólares eso generan organizaciones
criminales en contrabando de drogas oro
y combustible en venezuela así como
actividades ilegales en puertos y
aduanas de ese país según un informe
publicado por la ong transparencia
venezuela el organismo estima que el
volumen de las operaciones ilícitas es
equivalente al 21 por ciento del
producto interno bruto de ese país ahora
como siempre gracias por toda la
información económica en la segunda hora
directo américa más economía vamos a
alemania ahí está lista a nuestra vida
especial agrícola varia
[Música]